I continue to in bewildered fashion wait
for someone who is running against
Donald Trump in the 2024 nomination or
might soon be running against Trump to
Levy some kind of criticism of Donald
Trump some kind of policy critique draws
some distinction between what they would
do and what Donald Trump would do we
have a couple of examples here and the
one that is getting weirder and weirder
by the day is former South Carolina
governor and former ambassador to the
United Nations under Donald Trump Nikki
Haley Nikki Haley has announced that she
is running against Trump right okay good
so like what would you do differently
well nothing but I'm younger and I'm a
woman and I'm a minority identity
politics has been Nikki Haley's approach
so far it has now been weeks and Nikki
Haley went on Fox News and she was asked
are you going to draw any distinction
with Donald Trump and her latest thing
is well let's see if he criticizes me
first that you're not going to kick
sideways but we've seen Donald Trump on
the debate stage and I guarantee you he
will kick sideways and he will come
after you yeah
um and so and you're gonna have to stand
up to that kick back when I'm kicked I
kick back and what will your argument
against him
well let's wait and see if he's got a
criticism first he hasn't done anything
he hasn't said anything so I know
everybody wants that's very much untrue
talk about Trump but Martha truly and we
had a couple of thousand people in South
Carolina we had packed rooms in New
Hampshire not one person asked me about
Donald Trump not one and now we're in
Iowa people really want to talk about
the issues and I think that's a lot of
it they're done with the status quo
they're done with talking about all the
old school things they want to talk
about how we're going to go forward and
I think what we need to make sure we
tell American families is we're going to
stop this socialism creep that we're
seeing we're going to stop this any
criticisms of trump socialism is bad
fetism that's happened around our
country we're going to make people stand
for America again and be proud of
America yeah so remember she says as
soon as Trump criticizes me I will
criticize him Trump brutally criticized
her last week remember he he said she
was such a terrible Governor that he
made her Ambassador as a favor to the
people of South Carolina to get her out
of the state he posted quote on a true
social Trump posted last week the
greatest thing Nikki Haley did for our
country in the great state of South
Carolina was accepting the position of
U.N Ambassador so that the incredible
then Lieutenant Governor Henry McMaster
could be governor of South Carolina
where he has done an absolutely
fantastic job that was a big reason why
I appointed Nikki to the position it was
a favor to the people I love in South
Carolina she's basically saying I have
criticisms of trump but I'm going to
wait till he criticizes me hard to find
a more serious criticism than that and
then in addition to this Trump just a
few days ago saying there are people out
there with no polling support basically
auditioning for vice president when
Trump said the following nobody else was
running it was only Nikki Haley that
this could be applied to a lot of people
are right now auditioning you know that
a lot of people a lot of people that are
running at one percent two percent three
percent no percent
we have a couple that are joining
they're at no percent
I say I wonder what they're doing I
think they're auctioning right now for
they're auditioning right now for vice
president in a sense they are kind of
auctioning themselves off Trump's
Freudian slip there uh Trump slipped
there maybe more Freudian than we might
think uh but this was something we
suggested I kind of agree with Trump I
do think there is an element of let me
run to get attention but not criticize
Trump draw no distinctions whatsoever
from Trump on policy and see if maybe
that can get me the vice presidentship
so that's Nikki Haley still unwilling
unable whatever to draw any distinctions
other than identity distinctions between
her and the guy she is running against
let's next talk about another guy who
might be entering the race Tim Scott
I like wine but I know very little about
it and I am completely clueless when I
go to a wine shop I just don't know what
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm
looking at I couldn't tell you anything
about varietals or if there's hints of
Persimmon or any of it and so if you're
like me wishing you had a seasoned
expert by your side when you're choosing
wine crunchy red fruit is the answer
crunchy red fruit delivers Choice
handcrafted small production wines right
to your door every bottle is hand-picked
by owner and master sommelier Jackson
rohrba in Seattle and comes with food
pairing suggestions we've been chatting
with Jackson his curating puts an
emphasis on organic low intervention
wines wines without artificial yeasts or
chemicals crunchy red fruit sources from
small scale sustainable Vineyards and
only wines that are true to their
location and grape crunchy red fruits
bi-monthly wine club is called the
circle every two months you'll get three
or six bottles to enjoy with videos to
help you appreciate what you're drinking
go to crunchyredfruit.com use the code
Pacman for twenty dollars off a single
purchase or if you join their bi-monthly
wine club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below